move back ahead as Jenner finishes the check along
the wall again sent to the point long shot here
off the goal post off the Stick of gouie and part
of this new wave of defenseman that can definitely
shoot the Pucket goes off the knob over Rob moves
it to Center cross the line there's a shot mono
getting a chance to feel that pucking holds Mike
Mat to the line little head fake deals dropping a
pass there steer to Side by m lein Bean off the
wall but not out from the point lstr and that's
off the BL back Blocker of Elvis Mur lein getting
a lot of goals from their blue line but a lot of
wers in the montre Lina here on the turnover G cop
to the net monteno gets a piece of it thrown back
in front again Barona nice little scoring chance
and you can see when chikov starts moving and
attacking that's exactly in the corner there's
Jenner works against the pair of the Canadians
comes up jacket send to D Tod could Branson with
a shot it's blocked in front of montmo marchenko
hustles to the puck goodro will send it hard
good Branson again save monm both from behind
the net danth will step in and wins the face
could Branson up high lets it Fly mono the save
good work there by Dean the knock it back and deep
into Montreal territory baronov nice pass top of
the circle a shot monteno looks behind him it was
right there at the side what a nice pass there by
Demitri ronov heads up play and here's the shot
deflected mono finally gets it but nice little
release there by Co cyling went off a couple
sticks actually right there seven seven of the
shots long attempt here oh that one was deflected
in front as well and again it was baronov right
there on the doorstep here's a wraparound attempt
in the blue pain and it just trickles wide cyinder
was there Evans will play the puck wron C behind
the that puck retrieval here's a shot right here
second opportunity creating chaos trying to kick
it free over Savage Caufield the pass picked off
and an outstanding stop the left hand of mono
after that turn turn over wow and here's that
pick there by Zach orensky what a read and we
talked about Zack cyinder nice pass as he got
hit but makes the play it's two onone with chikov
cross ice in front oh my MBO he was able to stop
the shot by chikov who simply wanted to deposit
it Vincent and the blue jacket coaching staff
got to be pleased here but like to get a couple
behind mon B now we kind of miss him around just
a great personality and outstanding player on
the left wing trying to cut in dead forth does
gets away from the defender there kovas savich
but he could not pull the trigger take a look
at that great move there by Dan for keeping his
edge around kevich and he's trying to outweight
monomo back's got the skating legs going pumped
along the boards there Canadians bring it back in
Coffield with a shot and that's off the Blocker
of vers leak Cole Cofield he had the game winner
in overtime and MRE here coming quickly right
in and monteo can't take it Patrick l using his
feet race down the right wing and Tucks it home
again the Blue Jackets score first well Patrick
l Ain making things happen with his feet and you
don't see that explosion too often from him goes
past three Montreal Canadian as they're changing
ING with the perfect finish as he's being chased
by the Montreal defenseman Justin Baron and yes
he celebrates this one well done Patrick Patrick
l with a burst of speed and the puck trickle
jackets all over Montreal again here's texier
kicks from skate the stick sends it back to
the point kov unable to keep it in new hook
shoves ahead with Gallagher back to New Hook off
the goal poost had M Le speat it went right off
the pipe that's a second goal post for new hook
in this game another attempt shot block new hook
this time able to gather up that puck from the
slot missed as it went right off the pipe but
left alone in the slot he's tied it up and uh
the Montreal Canadian take advantage of it but
uh yeah let's take a look at that goal here by
new Hook is wide open Elvis coming from his right
to his left but what a pass by Nick Suzuki off
Kaden gulan and up over to new hook who finishes
this one after hitting the post dropped by baronov
marinsky cross I a lot of chatter on the ice can
hear it up here and I can tell you one of them is
the referee West mcau you can hear him everywhere
at the building oh leading one way and the puck
goes the other and the jackets of regain the lead
monteno went to play the puck on the right side it
went to the left side seems like everybody on the
ice touched the puck here it starts with that
turnover Zach rinsky is going to get that one
sending in front to Veron and then finally Shin's
going to get this one but that puck is going side
to side nice finish there by jagar chikov who
these two tried to collaborate early on a goal
and unfortunately chikov did not finish bar on the
blue line puck gets out of the Zone here's a break
gy goodro will pick it up mat trying to get back J
her in for deny when you got a guy that's playing
as well as mono in fact they kind of pulled a page
tell you about it here in a moment here moving in
shot save covering up no it's a loose Puck and
scores Elvis B leans unable to handle that Puck
and the Canadians for the second time have come
back to tie it here in the second period Patrick
ly losing his Edge right here at as it collides
and Elvis try to recover that puck but it's almost
like yeah Patrick Ling who makes a great job
making a come back through the slot there that
puck bounces back and right on the stick of
Cole Coffield who sparked right in front that
varries this one groud certainly appreciative
here's a break moving in armia save no rebound
and Elvis with a little slash there he doesn't
ice it he tried to get it deep get a change so
they're not stuck out there but Samuel mono good
recognition you see Joel armia going good job by
[Applause] Alvis from the corner knocked off the
wall Robinson comes up with it here's Bean to the
net goes off Dan forth who picks it up almost
got it a second time as mat moves it away from
the slot and here's Josh Anderson starts with
Eric Robinson they're going to send that puck
to the point here that's Puck bouncing now
Monahan backand Canadians come away to Center
left wing pass armia waits for it slides it ahead
that's Monahan to the point quite a crowd in front
this Puck drill and scores from up high mat we
talked about him in the open and his offensive
prowess he just set a Billet to the net on the
blue line it goes D to D and the young Justin
Baron's going to slide over to Madison as we
take a look at that that replay here there's
a little bit of a delay and he slies across
and that's a moving screen in front there and
uh yes indeed it was tipped by Joel Arma Puck s
High Suzuki tried to come up with it it's banked
ahead and picked up by the Canadians deep armia
with the go-ahead goal tries to slap It Off the
Wall to himself from up high mat less than
a minute to go Puck drilled and in Canadians
scored two quick goals and now lead 4-2 with
the empty net there was no hesitation from
Montreal at all two guys below the goal line
despite the Mt net and they basically set up
just like a a goal tender was there and it goes
over to Lindstrom who puts that one in the mtet
puck dumped in that'll do it Canadians come
from behind Aria with the game-winning goal